j'en connais une autre qui va nous
prouver que dans la bibliothèque de vous
êtes formidable il y a des trésors et à
chaque fois elle va nous chercher des
choses incroyables vous nous mettez du
baume au coeur aujourd'hui Tiphaine on a
une question comme difficile qui est
posée par votre sélection littérature
jeunesse vous nous le disiez tout à
l'heure en début d'émission comment être
un bon roi alors j'ai envie de dire
faut-il être raisonnable éclairer
impulsif passionné un peu un peu
déglingué en tout cas plusieurs auteurs
se penchent sur cette question et ça
donne de très jolies fables comme ce
bouquin que vous avez là et je crois que
ça vient de Pologne c'est ça oui tout à
fait et en plus alors ça a donné le nom
à la chronique j'ai commencé directement
par celui-ci ça s'appelle comme il est
difficile d'être roi et c'est de yanish
korchak et Ivona schmiliefk publié aux
éditions format alors l'histoire est
simple c'est un enfant qui se retrouve
propulsé sur le trône du jour au
lendemain et le roi Mathias lui n'a que
alors vous vous imaginez bien qui veut
prendre des conseils et l'enfant auprès
de ces ministres auprès d'autres
souverains mais comme c'est un enfant il
a aussi ses propres idées il adore le
chocolat et il décide que les enfants
doivent avoir plus de pouvoir alors ils
créent un parlement des enfants alors
vous vous en doutez tout ne se passe pas
comme prévu il prend des décisions un
peu surprenantes et la démocratie qui
est un art difficile évolue et bien pas
toujours dans le bon sens au départ il
est adulé puis il finit relativement
détesté alors vous le voyez les
illustrations sont très jolies et elles
permettent et bien de donner un nouveau
souffle à un compte qui date de 1923
figurez-vous puisque au départ et bien
c'était déjà un livre pour enfants de
yanish corschak vous je vous l'ai dit
qu'il voulait et bien interroger les
enfants sur ses difficultés à prendre
des décisions et à être un bon
politicien alors je vous le conseille
c'est à partir de 17 ans et puis et bien
ça permettra de discuter avec les
enfants de cette idée de pouvoir et de
devenir roi Pascal si jamais ça vous
tente en reconversion peut-être je sais
pas si lave pas proposer ça je suis pas
sûr pas certain pas certain en tout cas
vous serez marraine ça c'est sûr le roi
Mathias premier j'ai bien noté si comme
le jeune Mathias il se passe de d'autres
choses on va chercher dans la
bibliothèque et je crois que là vous
avez trouvé un autre roi plein de bonnes
volonté seul problème ah oui c'est le
problème là aussi toute ressemblance
avec des faits existants orientés
peut-être pas fortuite il a des
problèmes à gouverner
oui parce qu'il est honnête parce que je
ne sais pas si c'est une qualité pour un
roi je vous laisserai juger hein
derrière votre votre écran et c'est un
livre de Kim froissant et Théophile
Sutter publié par les éditions Gauthier
langro alors honnête c'est son nom et
c'est aussi je voulais dire ça qualité
principale au départ en tout cas alors
son goût pour la vérité ben le pouce a
interdire les contes de fées les
histoires les mensonges le problème
c'est que parmi ces conseillers il y a
malice et ma liste lui il décide de
mettre en place une police politique qui
vérifie que seule la vérité à court dans
ce royaume alors évidemment et bien les
opposants se retrouvent en prison un
petit peu comme d'habitude j'ai envie de
dire alors ce compte et cette faible est
très bien menée puisque le raisonnement
est implacable et on finit par
comprendre que le droit à l'intimité et
le droit aux rêves et aux histoires et
bien c'est quand même fondamental vous
le voyez les illustrations sont
magnifiques avec une vraie recherche sur
les polices euh les polices de caractère
des décors pop quelques références par
exemple aux Trois Brigands ça plaira
énormément aux adultes et aux enfants
j'invite les adultes d'ailleurs à
chercher des petites références
politiques dans les bulles c'est à
partir de 8 ans c'est un grand format
j'adore ça je vous le conseille ça
s'appelle le roi honnête parfait allez
on dit jamais 230 on va terminer avec un
troisième ouvrage moral
tyrannie et aventure je fais le tiercé
je fais pas le quartier le quinté parce
que j'ai pas le temps sur les grands
thèmes du troisième livre de votre
bibliothèque c'est un roman pour ado
finalement oui à partir de 15 ans ça
s'appelle le dernier lion d'albâtre
c'est de Dana chalice et c'est publié
chez golf stream alors c'est une
aventure initiatique vous vous plongez
dedans vous ne pouvez pas le refermer ça
parle de deux ados alors astéry et
pitana alors astéry et bien c'est une
jeune voleuse orpheline et esclave et
l'autre et bien c'était un jeune prince
qui fait partie
lignée d'oppresseurs esclavagiste je
vous donne le tableau vous vous imaginez
qu'ils vont avoir du mal au départ à
s'entendre mais il faut absolument qu'il
trouve le dernier lion d'albâtre qui est
celui qui va pouvoir les sauver d'un
fléau qui ravage tous les royaumes à
l'entour on ne sait pas qui est ce
dernier lion d'albâtre c'est une
aventure initiatique et magique je vous
le conseille et surtout et bien tous les
royaumes sont inspirés de tradition
asiatique alors on retrouve des
références allégypte ça plaît beaucoup
en général aux ados et ça permet
d'aborder et bien des problématiques
intéressantes pourquoi disparaissent les
civilisations est-ce qu'on a de bonnes
raisons de faire la guerre à ses voisins
et puis peut-on tolérer l'esclavage et
puis enfin évidemment vous l'avez
compris parce que peut-on être un bon
roi parfait vous êtes formidable merci
Tiphaine la sélection livre de la région
et d'ailleurs à retrouver aussi sur le
net et les réseaux sociaux ne se quitter
Tiphaine à votre avis à quoi est-ce que
vous pouvez ressembler le diable
rapidement
le diable et bien en général une
personne très sympathique qui cache bien
son jeu très bien on donnera pas de nom
on va se faire que des copains autrement
et des copines